va falloir tout nous raconter je vous
dirais que dalle allez vous faire
profiter toute la journée ça me fera
croire perso moi de mon côté je vous
dirai tout ce que c'est toi tu déconnes
michael bryce voulait oublier ce passé
songer à une reconversion
professionnelle répétez après moi je ne
suis plus gardes du corps je ne suis
plus les gardes du corps mais le passé
sur j'ai à nouveau rappelé victor garcia
ce qu'il doit protéger la femme du plus
cinglés détruire qu'est ce qu'il faut
ici lui j'ai dit trouve qui tu veux à
part michael wright je pense que tu
voulais dire merci en quatre jours
touteleurope brûlera
une met sur pied une cyberattaque géante
attention vous ne devez pas merdé
ne vous inquiétez pas on va perdre et
j'ai promis à ma thérapeute je ne
protège plus personne noire était il
faut qu'ils restent concentrés
jérémy vous inquiétez pas je conduis pas
ce que vous avez à faire
faut que tu appuyer un peu sur le frein
il faut que tu nous protège on essaie
d'avoir un bébé
puisses-tu avoir pitié de nos salles
répète appelle moi j'ai pas de licence
et pas de licence c'est tellement plus
fort c'est pas de licence mais j'en ai
rien à [ __ ]
il nous faut des armes
il faut débattre
il nous faut c'est ça vous êtes prêt à
vous défoncer quoi ça peut prêter à
confusion pas vous défoncer l'un l'autre
mais avec nous mais ça peut aussi prêter
à confusion
alors faisons ce qu'on sait faire le
mieux allons tout faire exploser
[Musique]
oui mais je trie pas une super maman est
franchement merci c'est sur menthon
désintérêt total pour le sec ce qui fait
de toi un homme de grande écoute
[Musique]
je voudrais vous faire remarquer que
nous sommes en sécurité
c'est vraiment comme un nouveau des
quinze -16 117
je vous présente en essais smith à lille
1 117 ssf le vrai l'unique la légende
l'ema boîte carrée beaucoup serge est
notre toute nouvelle recrue qui nous
rappelle louis à 30 ans commence à
porter immédiatement on a fait
bienvenue monsieur préserve suit la
charge et ayant tél
c'est un plaisir pour la clientèle de
vos avoirs pilchard j allais prendre mon
slip de bain qui ne manquait rien
maintenant non voulez-vous que je vous
réserve une table pour ce soir ma foi ce
serait l impossible à crolles un nom
c'est à dire de nos dix dents dehors ce
soir peut-être que bientôt nous pour
nous
bien sûr cousin qu'est ce que c'est que
ce foutoir
du plaisir féminin bien dormi comme un
bébé et vous comme adam
[Musique]
jg je vous écoute messieurs qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans votre région nom de
dieu je viens de découvrir que le diable
on a sûrement dit économiser assez
maintenant pour t'acheter un lopin de
terre donc qui pourrait peut-être d'en
acheter un tu cherche à vendre
fais-moi une proposition pour ça jamais
de la vie
pour 4 litres de pétrole brut extrait de
cette parcelle 160 litres d'eau
catastrophique pour tout quitter l'ol
problème à part le fait que ces
radioactifs ou pas du le cancer c'est de
la blague
[Musique]
je royce empoisonne la propriété peut
pas prouver que ces oeufs frais il faut
des propose cinquante mille pour
l'ensemble payer en une fois c'est une
harde à il a flairé quelque chose comme
sodie une chose sur le fait de
sous-estimer son adversaire quoi ne le
faites pas si vous me laissez pas tomber
monsieur stearns je viendrai me servir
jusqu'à tout prendre je suis payé pour
ça on sera réglé aujourd'hui
non je ne le sais pas père combes maire
jean reuilles savez tout depuis le début
et n'ont absolument rien fait si ce
n'est des bénéfices
il n'y a pas que cet endroit dis moi que
tu n'as pas signé cette vente
combien vous demandez tout le monde a un
prix ils essaient de m'acheter pour
50000 misérable dollars il ne montrait
pas à 60-70 combien ils ont gagné en
empoisonnant mater 2 milliard cent
millions de dollars et ça c'est juste
sur une année 2 milliard cent millions
tu te moques de moi à leurs six fermes y
venait à remporter une victoire dans ce
procès il devrait inévitablement un
précédent la chasse sera ouverte contre
les compagnies la règle de la valeur
nette actualisée
si vous gagnez plus d'argent en faisant
ce que vous faites que cela vous en
compression ou puni c'est pour l'avoir
fait alors continue à le faire
des fermiers de ce pays se suicident
tous les jours de la semaine vous voulez
être sur la liste
[Musique]
je crois bien que tu vas pas pouvoir
t'en tirer comme ça lisez les indiens au
chef de la cavalerie
[Musique]
quand j'avais ton âge moi aussi j'ai
déménagé
tu vas tu y habituer on verra on va être
heureux là bas je te promets
mon ange
puissamment nous confie plus jamais
comme ça tu m'entends bonjour maman ou
tu les a trouvés vous avez déjà regardé
votre enfant sans parvenir à le
reconnaître il est méconnaissable
attention ce n'est pas votre fils ne lui
voulait aucun mal vous savez
chris lui rappelle notre fils défunt
que lui est il arrivé
elle était convaincue que c'était un
imposteur
[Musique]
c'est pas crise c'est pas lui
y at il des antécédents médicaux dans
votre famille quelque chose ne va pas tu
n'es pas mon fils
dis moi la vérité c'est ce que je fais
arrête de mentir et non pas
[Musique]
où es tu
c'est faux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
michalak
j
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
belote et frère il faut absolument
retrouver quelqu'un pour ta compagnie
plus tout seul non non non comprenez
vraiment pour anase en fait non je
plaisante mais si tu veux non pas ton
père se plaît ya quand je les ai ramenés
à la comédie française ne s'est pas trop
mal perçu c'est hors de question
used
ils sont tous dans la couchette existe
ni tant que jeune homme il mènerait pas
un peu à monter une autre dont le talent
face pour ambre au maire dit beauchemin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de merde j'ai encore eu mon billet
suivant bonjour voila j'ai vraiment cru
qu'il était parti dans le train le voilà
je vous goûtez va dans le train
évidemment
sont dans un train il peut pas leur
arriver grand chose si au contraire il
peut se passer n'importe quoi ils ont
retenu qu à sagelat
obama c'était juste pour savoir si vous
étiez bien l'arrivée d'abord ma chérie
vérité dans un trinquet ce que dieu qui
se passe
sculpture folle et vous avez été un peu
oublié de payer l'essence
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai marre vous comprenez vous faites
ce que vous voulez je m'en fous mais moi
je lâche pas
[ __ ] y'a gendarmes tanvir a dû voir
vos gueules c'est vrai que c'est marrant
[Musique]
ici le 911
comment puis-je vous avez monsieur j'ai
besoin de savoir où vous êtes afin de
pouvoir vous envoyer de l'aide est ce
que tu vas bien
je tout va bien sergent
tu as sauvé la vie de cette petite fille
ce soir peu de gens se rendent compte de
l'énorme fardeau que nous portons kate
arbore et l'insigne ça fait partie de
notre boulot tu ferais bien te ramener l
ouvrir une enquête
nous avons reçu des informations
déroutantes
l'appel était un canular enfin comment
des trucs pareils arrive je n'ai entendu
crier depuis la rue je les jugeais sur
son apparence
c'est une affaire très complexe c'était
un mari un père tu peux pas la laisser
comme ça je ne sais pas quoi lui dire et
les choses bien
bouge ton cul je viens dans le cadre
d'une enquête sur un homicide
un homme est mort le suspect est
toujours en cavale je ne veux pas tu
entraîné dans cette chute
tu ne m'entraîne orient je ne sois pas
déjà si ton épouse dix mois ce qui se
passe
[Musique]
s'il bat sans autorisation je pourrai
pas lui venir en aide
il faut qu'on parle je sais quel genre
de fille tu tu crois que ça fait quoi de
pointer le choc sur quelqu'un tu as du
mal à respirer
donc tu as accès lire tu entends ton
vous qui bat dans this way
il a rendu son dernier souffle son
angoisse et est tout seul
il faut leur rendre justice
[Musique]
des hivers marseille 1 2 point
à barbie comme taiwo 6 mois
soit
enfin
il ya une masse iphone guichet
je m'endors
avec son style est possible et cela en
arabe
le masseur
monsieur mêmes moyens
singer
rocard
blague à part
au caire
m
police parce que tu n'as pas peur
neeson diane maarek lehman a que faire
bienvenue aux oscars
vidéo
il disait crosby
[Musique]
mais là pas de patrouille le film
quand tout espoir semble perdu et c'est
qu'en plus que jamais on a besoin de
héros
notre destin est tentant
leurs pattes un show pour être exact je
suis un chien selon coup vous êtes sous
le choc je vais pas me vexer pour ça cet
été encore un parquet sauvetage
le phénomène mondial débarque au cinéma
pas de patrouille quel est le problème
je m'appelle liberty vous devez les
aider messieurs olinger va détruire
aventure ville
on est parti il faut sauver aventure
ville
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre nouveau quartier
général
cette embrouille avec son distributeur
de friandises high tech
en quoi c'est une pure merveille
pas de chien ordres du nouveau maire
will est plutôt branché ma toutes les
taxes et messieurs et par dessus tout
influenceurs avec plus de 10000
followers
il est temps d'embrasser il faut sauver
ces gens tout ce travail là pas de
patrouille
c'est pas possible je m'en charge des
gages de la bouche faut savoir employer
les bons mots à l'ayroule
[Musique]
extraction
c'est notre mission on devine est trop
grande car les amis bien sûr
des mini-drones
ou c'est moche qui vous nomme tous les
deux à la tête du service rugolo le riz
et notre appui vous n'engagez plus de
terreur a lieu les terreurs bonjour les
blagueurs affecté à la mif c'est quoi
exactement l'amista à laisser partir la
maintenons un terme fort style humaine
qui quand une machine a besoin d'être
entretenue pour l'entretien at war
personne n'arrive à personne n'ait rien
fait
[Musique]